verdict guilty signed by the four lady
date 3 2 of 23. a jury found former
South Carolina lawyer Alec Murdock
guilty of murdering his wife Maggie and
his son Paul at their family hunting
estate in 2021.
the case attracted national attention
and he may be taken away
included hundreds of pieces of evidence
a jury visit to the crime scene and
testimony from more than 70 Witnesses
including Murdoch himself who pleaded
not guilty to the murder charges I am
going to test that I want to testify so
here's a look back at some of the key
moments from the trial and what happens
next Mr good and I didn't shoot my wife
or my son any time
ever he's a trial lawyer right for more
than 25 years and so he knows how to
talk to a jury and he turned to them and
told them his story me and my boys
laying face down Murdoch spent hours
answering questions from his own lawyers
admitting to the jury that he lied to
investigators about his whereabouts on
the night of the killings because he was
addicted to opioids
yes sir that's what it looks like
I wasn't thinking clearly
I don't think I was capable of reason
and I lied about being down there he
also admitted to misleading and stealing
money from clients at his Law Firm he's
been jailed for more than a year on 99
counts primarily related to those
charges and he's pleaded not guilty to
most of them
during cross-examination the state
focused on Murdoch's admitted pattern of
lying seeking to paint him as
untrustworthy and what happened in this
case
I stole her money
at times it was just Relentless hours of
asking him well did you sit across the
table from this client and lie to their
face just like you have lied to many
people with the implication being are
you lying to this jury right now the
defense argued that the state failed to
provide direct evidence like a
confession eyewitness accounts or a
weapon proving that Murdoch murdered his
wife and son instead the state relied on
circumstantial evidence including data
related evidence pulled from Murdoch's
car and cell phone they just really
built a lot of the case on the steps on
elec Murdoch's phone what time he drove
by the spot where Maggie Murdoch's phone
was found the next day they had a lot of
data-driven testimony that sought to
demonstrate that Eric Murdoch was the
person who did these things meanwhile
the defense called out the destruction
of the shirt Murdoch war on the night of
the murders and a poorly investigated
crime scene footprint as examples of
mistakes made by invest
the prosecution has said yes we
acknowledge this shirt was destroyed yes
the footprint was not analyzed as it
might have been but there is absolutely
no evidence no DNA no fingerprints no
ballistics nothing that shows that
anybody else other than elec Murdoch
could have been there and committed
these horrible Acts
the state needed to prove to the jury
that Murdoch was guilty Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt the fact that it is a
circumstantial case creates a lot of
runway for the defense to bring in um
areas of that might create Reasonable
Doubt in the mind of the jury such as
the possibility of two Shooters the fact
that Maggie and Paul were killed with
two different weapons which were never
recovered and the angle of the bullet
wounds they brought in an expert who who
who kind of demonstrated through a
presentation where were these shots
coming from and how tall would the
person have to have been let's say if
you put a five four person even
or five five five six
um in kind of that shooting position
from the hip you've got to move them all
the way up to the quail pin and it
doesn't make any sense there because
there's no shell casings based on the
angles of the bullet entry wounds on
Paul's body the defense team's analyst
testified that the shooter couldn't have
been taller than five foot two Murdoch
is more than six feet tall
after the jury's verdict Murdoch will
still face prosecution for the financial
crimes he allegedly committed It's
tricky to know what happens to all those
charges because in the course of his
testimony ellic essentially said yes I
lied and I stole money from these people
that wasn't mine repeatedly so it's not
clear what happens with the prosecution
of those charges when he's already
essentially confessed from the witness
stand
[Music]